i'm very happy for you you're a lovely
person and uh it's going so well for you
i'm really happy that you're nominated
for all these emmys you're crushing it
you're out there killing it and you're a
very good person you really are thank
you you are you know that yeah i try to
be a good person i try i don't know
sometimes
no i think i'm a good person you are you
are all joking aside you're a good
person thank you yeah and i know i
really had to think about it i was like
am i
who was i mean to today nobody no you
are you're you're just incessantly kind
to people when you have such a good
spirit oh thank you no i'm i'm just uh i
feel the same way about you well thank
you you are kind you gave me my first
late night appearance and late night is
funny because they're like well you have
to have it tape to get the you know to
book the spot and i'm like well how do
you get the tape if no one will let you
on right and then you let me on which
was really kind of you well it was also
it was smart because you really make me
laugh so
and uh and al also i really loved our
different appearances together because
you were so good at being funny and nice
and generous and then uh but also really
making me squirm in a way that people
absolutely love
you know and it was just real that's
what i loved about it is that it was so
real
yeah it's just it's fun it's fun to play
off of you it's a you're a very giving
comedian like you're yeah and naturally
there's some uptights uh stuff catholic
stuff there that put us together and
people would be like oh my god this is
fantastic i love this so it's fun we
have to uh we have to take this act on
the road someday
let's do it yes i would do it yeah we
got to figure something out we got to do
something together where we bottle that
first yes just a little bit of time sell
it to people and make lots of money no
we'll give it away money money
[Laughter]
you've changed
um please come back soon cause i love
talking to you or i'll come visit you
but this was great thank you you're
gonna come visit me where did you go
well no i wouldn't just show up at your
post but i mean i'll show up on your
pockets one of your
projects by that'd be nice wait do you
have a best friend
a best friend yeah so she and i have a
podcast called best friends
and um
we interview best friends sometimes oh
that's nice who's your best friend well
here's the problem if i say my best
friend it's gonna
people might get angry
upset
what because guess what big shocker it's
not gorelin
it was until like a day ago
when you started having a meltdown on
the podcast
[Laughter]
i'm gonna throw out my god oral sex idea
just see how it goes
i stand by it yeah you should uh nicole
thank you so so much for coming here i
know you're really i know you're really
busy and it was nice of you and it made
everyone everyone's day here so thank
you oh well thank you for having me this
was fun okay i'll truly come back any
old time and i'm gonna find you this
fella
you only wrote down six too
i have the full list here
he has the full list six two i only i
retrieved the pen late and then i didn't
want to write big dick
and six two to six five employed nice
handsome sense of humor titty honking
hands and big dick or a kind dick
yeah yeah got it kind nice yeah the
proper amount of veins yeah well what
did you do how would you like that
the proper amount of pains
it was all coming together so nicely and
this is important how many veins where
are the veins yeah how much what's that
what's too many it's too many veins
too many's where you're like ah this one
looks angry
you know where it looks like the hulk's
arm that's too many well maybe it's
having a stroke or something
no hulk's arm and what no it's too few
veins um one we are like is it alive
they do make little shocking paddles for
penises
try it again
i am ready to go
no no take it easy relax
breathe we'll get jumping around
oh i don't know what happened it blacked
out
things started to heat up and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
all the penises that i give life to
always work at the library
oh sorry i fainted there i just got a
little nervous
you okay now
we had to shock you back
i gotta get back to the rare book
library that i work in